Speaker 1: So we were looking at the hearing
that took place yesterday, Senate hearing
with Dr. Anthony Fauci and CDC Director Rochelle
Walensky about the pandemic.
Rand Paul and Dr. Fauci's confrontation we
already looked at.
The funniest moment is that after Republican
Senator Roger Marshall said all sorts of stupid
things and asked really dumb questions.
Dr. Fauci was caught on.
It's being called a hot mic.
Dr. Fauci, you may have known that the mike
was on.
I mean, who knows, maybe he did this on purpose
saying what a moron, followed by Jesus Christ.
I just absolutely love this.
Let's take a look.
The clip going viral instantly.
Look, I
Speaker 3: know I'm feeling totally incorrect.
Speaker 2: We look forward to reviewing it.
Speaker 4: Senator Marshall, Dr. Fauci has
answered you to is public information, and
he's happy to give it to you.
If you were to ask Senator Moran,
Speaker 3: what a more serious question.
Speaker 1: What a moron it is.
An exasperated Dr. Anthony Fauci.
And you know what?
Roger Marshall is a moron without any moron
is to light a term to apply to him.
Here's some of Roger Marshall's questioning
Speaker 2: Dr. Fauci, according to Forbes.
You have an annual salary in 2020 was four
hundred and thirty four thousand dollars.
You oversee over five billion.
Speaker 1: They actually put up like a blown
up fake novelty check.
This is about the pandemic, I thought,
Speaker 2: or in federal research grants as
the highest paid employee in the entire federal
government.
Yes or no, would you be willing to submit
to Congress and the public?
A financial disclosure that includes your
past and current investments?
After all, your colleague, Dr. Wilensky, and
every member of Congress submits a financial
disclosure that includes their investments.
Speaker 1: Now, here's a mic off moment, then
he turns his mic on.
Speaker 3: I don't understand why you're asking
me that question.
My financial disclosure is public knowledge
and has been so for the last thirty seven
years or so.
Thirty five.
Speaker 1: The reason he's asking it, even
though the financial disclosures are already
public, is he wants brownie points from the
right for doing it in a hearing.
Speaker 2: The Big Tech giants are doing an
incredible job of keeping it from being public.
We'll continue to look for it.
Where would we find it?
Speaker 3: All you have to do is ask for it.
You're so misinformed.
It's extraordinarily
Speaker 2: misinformed.
This is a huge issue.
Wouldn't you agree with me that that you have
a you see things before members of Congress
would see them so that there's an air of appearance
that that maybe some shenanigans are going
on.
Speaker 1: There is an air of appearance that
some shenanigans are going on.
Man, this guy is a moron.
Fauci was right,
Speaker 3: but I assume that that's not the
case.
Are you talking about the case?
My my financial disclosures are public knowledge
and have been so you are getting amazingly
wrong information.
Speaker 2: So what I cannot by name our office
cannot find.
Speaker 1: He can't find them, so Fauci must
be hiding them.
Think about that
Speaker 2: logic.
Where would they be if their public knowledge?
Speaker 3: Where it is totally accessible
to you if you want it for the public?
Is it accessible to the public, to the public?
Right?
We look at anyone feeling totally incorrect.
We look forward
Speaker 2: to reviewing
Speaker 1: it.
It is really stunning.
This guy truly, truly, truly a moron and just
on his political positions.
Roger Marshall doesn't even want abortion
to be legal in cases of rape and incest.
That's a moronic position to take.
It's an immoral position during COVID.
Marshall promoted conspiracy theories that
the CDC is exaggerating COVID deaths.
This is like stuff from from the, you know,
the cesspool of Facebook.
Facebook has even removed Marshall's posts
because they were harmful misinformation,
and Facebook allows tons of harmful misinformation.
He was promoting hydroxychloroquine prophylactically
when it was unproven, and it's since been
debunked.
Roger Marshall said, I'm not even sure that
there is climate change.
This guy is a moron.
And of course, he's in favor of repealing
Obamacare.
Dr. Fauci was right, and unfortunately, these
Republicans are going to COVID hearings and
asking about everything other than actual
questions about COVID.
If you want to see these clips, you're just
listening today, you want to see the clips.
We'll have them up on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show, and you
can also follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.